[Music]
you may
say that i'm a dreamer but i'm not the
only one i felt like i had to
[Music]
stop in front of this van and
have a moment with it for this this van
speaks to me in all kinds of ways this
van
is a bit like a psychedelic pop song
this van is a state of mind in a state
of being and a way of seeing the
world it is an expression of a
particular sensibility
of what you might call flower power
and it says so much with its artistry
and its
playfulness and the whimsical quality
with which it
hints at a world beyond the default
when baseline reality dissolves and a
new reality emerges in its pixelating
wake
one that says one that says life
is bananas one that says keep calm
and carry on one that features cannabis
marijuana next to gandhi next to
beautiful hallucinogenic
flowers next to roses next to peace
signs
for all of these things together in the
psychedelic volkswagen
van represent an intersection
that becomes a way of being in a way of
seeing that says no war
only peace and love keep calm and carry
on
let us get high let us practice peace
let us be like niza gardata who said the
other world
is this world rightly seen let us be
like the psychedelic surfer the surfer
that reflects the lifestyle
of the liberated self as timothy leary
says your future
is right in front of you your past is
exploding behind you
your footprints are being washed from
the shore it's a non-depletive
non-extractive act done solely for the
pleasure of the act itself
and that is the destiny of man right all
of these things expressed
in this psychedelic van now as we
continue to proceed we start seeing
counter-culture figures of rebellion
even though
some of their politics i don't agree
with but nonetheless they represent
subversive thinking that questions the
status quo
and as we continue to explore its
psychedelic
rhapsody we finally are left with the
question that says what would scooby doo
what would scooby doo what would scooby
doo what would you do well i'd go
on a mythic search i'd leave everything
behind i'd get my
psychedelic camper van and take off for
the great
unknown right as walker percy wrote the
search
for some something else or somewhere
else the search
is what everyone would undertake if they
were not sunk in the everydayness of
their own
lives and just to become aware of the
possibility of the search just to become
aware
of the possibility of the search is to
be onto something
and not to be on to something friends is
to be
in despair not to be onto something
is to be in despair the reason people
feel so lost
the people the reason people feel so
disconnected is because they're not
on a mythic quest they're not onto
something they're not engaged
by anything they're not impassioned by
anything they're stuck
in the everydayness of their own lives
and they're not even aware
of the possibility of being on to
something different right but
we have no choice we have to wake
ourselves up for as david foster wallace
said the alternative to this
the alternative to awakening and
illumination the alternative
of cleansing our doors of perception is
the alternative is unconsciousness the
default setting
the rat race the constant
gnawing sense of having had and lost
some infinite thing
and i will not go quietly into that good
night
i will rage and rage against the dying
of this light whereas once i was
blind now i can see
now i can see now
we must see
you feel me do you feel me
stay with me
just want to make sure that landed right
just want to make sure
that it's sinking in that you have no
choice
that the price of admission is nothing
less than everything
all right are you ready
get set go